mais oh oui vous celui qui a l'air
d'avoir une gueule de bois de la mort
qui tue
j'ai presque honte d'interrompre votre
convalescence mais c'est un plaisir de
se revoir à l'occasion de ce land man
fait si jamais certains d'entre vous ont
surpris que netflix lance son année 2010
8 avec une tête de con si vous faites
certainement partie de ces gens qui ne
savent pas apprécier la beauté de
quelqu'un qui brûleraient votre maison
allumez vos écrans et vous y découvrirez
la saison 2 des désastreuses aventures
des orphelins baudelaire qui le 30 mars
saura aiguiser votre curiosité
dans l'est au feu
suis-je une vision de cauchemar
parce que c'était cet effet là que
j'espère